[Music]
I'm not really sure how well seasonal
content does on YouTube Compared to TV
but there's no shortage of holiday
specials on television both new and old
even in superhero action cartoons badass
action figure selling Heroes want to
kick back and drink hot cocoa by the
fire near the end of the year too and
once again we're looking over some of
these Yuletide superhero shenanigans
I realize that no one wants to watch a
Christmas special on Christmas because
they're too busy going to two different
houses full of tension after the divorce
and the next day said Christmas special
will be irrelevant because they're
playing with their new video games and
prepping for an alcohol induced blackout
on New Year's so let's play it safe and
put this out a little bit before
Christmas
you know while you're still in the mood
I expect those views on the 26th to drop
harder than a lump of coal into a
stocking but it's too damn fun not to do
this topic so let's go cuddle up in a
warm blanket pour some milk grab a plate
of cookies and put on that itchy hat
[Music]
did anyone else think his name was
actually static shock as a kid
I didn't realize it was just static
until I was like 14. let's start with
the best episode on this list
static shocks episode Frozen out is
fantastic it's dramatic heartbreaking
heartwarming and a great watch
while prepping for the usual holiday
festivities Virgil Hawkins AKA static
has a few violent encounters with a
young girl with the ability to control
the weather and freeze things eventually
he learns more about her and finds out
that she's homeless and a lot of their
battles were actually total
misunderstandings because her powers
aren't in complete control and she came
from an abusive home and lost her mother
instead of beating her in a physical
battle he just reaches out to her on a
human level and tells her she doesn't
need to be scared of him anymore Virgil
learns an important lesson about not
looking past the homeless or making
assumptions about them because of the
position they're in and helps her get
off the streets and somewhere safer it's
not afraid to go a little dark and
serious but pulls back at the end for a
very wholesome conclusion hey look
there's Richie's dad
ish
one thing I really appreciate about this
episode is that they aren't too afraid
to touch on the religious aspect of the
holiday season and directly acknowledge
what static's faith is but the show
isn't like exclusive about it and has
him hanging out with his friends that
don't celebrate Christmas too like his
Jewish friend from school at her
Hanukkah party they also go to an
Interfaith church service that brings
the entire Community together at the end
of the episode
something about just saying what it is
feels very uniquely static shock because
this show never tried to pull punches
with content in the same way other
Superhero Cartoons did
drugs are mentioned gang violence is
shown there's a school shooting in one
episode and they even directly address
the topic of racism and static
being very upfront and honest about this
stuff also reminds me of that
embarrassingly bad moon night Christmas
episode of Ultimate Spider-Man where it
seemed like he wasn't actually allowed
to say the name of any holiday
so you just keep saying
the holidays like it was Auto filled
into the script for that episode I've
never spent the holidays away from her
sorry clothes for the holidays but if
you want to give New York City a
lifetime of holiday nightmares you're
definitely on the right track I've seen
some really bad holiday decorations but
those are the worst happy holidays
everybody okay just be honest with us we
all know Spider-Man's Jewish come on
just say it frock
why do these episodes always start with
the characters going to the mall is
because this is the one time of the year
that rampant consumerism and
irresponsible shopping sprees feel okay
because you're at least buying [ __ ] for
other people
yeah the animation isn't the best in
these first two seasons of the show
because the budget was lower and I'm
certain WB didn't expect this to be a
major hit so the characters are flat
colors with no shading and the movement
is a little awkward at times looking
back on it now it's cool to see the show
started so humble and then got a major
upgrade later when they brought it into
dcau but for now this episode isn't
really at the top of the list because of
its Stellar fight scenes or animation or
anything it's just because of how mature
and heartfelt the script is it went for
something more close to reality instead
of your usual Christmas Carol parody or
just beating a villain dressed to Santa
all the rest of these are that though
don't worry
thinking of beating a villain dressed as
Batman the Brave and the Bold has always
been a favorite of mine because the way
it balances absurdity and sincerity this
episode invasion of the secret Santas is
no exception the main focus of this
episode is actually on Red Tornado
instead of Batman tornado is an Android
superhero that wants to understand and
adapt human emotions making the holiday
season especially difficult because he
can't quite relate to everyone else's
festiveness
not for lack of trying he's trying his
best to get into the Christmas spirit in
his own bizarre robotic way and it's not
quite working
jingle bells jingle bells jingle all the
way
then he's called into action when Batman
needs his help to stop Alien Invaders
and an original villain created for the
show named Funhouse a villain that was
better when he was named inside gaming
funhouse's evil plan is to steal
valuables from every family in the city
on Christmas morning by selling
miniature robot thieves to them and the
guys of the holiday season's most
popular toy imagine if turbo man robbed
you at gunpoint
or a good guy doll actually that one
would definitely happen sure how do you
want it broken leg
for an episode that's so silly and
cheery it's kind of dark to reveal that
Batman's parents in this universe were
killed on Christmas day of all days yet
somehow this is one of the least
depressed Batman variants across the
Multiverse not sure how that tracks
maybe it's just so sad that he rubber
banded back to being a more
light-hearted Dark Knight instead
what sort of horrific nauseating tragedy
led to Adam West's Batman if that's the
case there's a lot of sadness behind
that batuzi the name for that dance
can't work anymore in 2023 it just
sounds like I'm talking about his bed OC
eventually Red Tornado and bats find
themselves fighting an army of evil
robot Santas because why not and Red
Tornado pushes himself a bit too hard
during the battle it turns out the
sensation of Christmas spirit filling
his body is actually just
don't worry you'll be all right he's an
automaton
[Music]
haven't really watched this show before
watch the live action one with Patrick
Warburton growing up and I like that one
a lot but this cartoon was just never
really on TV when I was a kid I gotta
say after seeing one episode I totally
get why this one is so beloved and keeps
coming back around every few years it's
hilarious
[Music]
in a world that's sort of overpopulated
with c-list superheroes with somewhat
stupid gimmicks the taking is pal Arthur
get ready for the Christmas season when
they come across a criminal in a Santa
suit being pursued by the police
The Tick is extremely naive and innocent
so he naturally assumes this is the real
Santa after a goofy super villain origin
accident the criminal Santa gains the
ability to duplicate himself and becomes
a one-man crime wave against the city
The Tick's childlike belief in Santa
makes him too afraid to fight back
against him until he gets a reality
check from the real Santa
I like this Show's take on Santa Claus
as like a really busy celebrity that
needs his own elf and security detail
like he's the president or something in
general I just find remixes of Santa as
something more serious is a really funny
concept like fat man violent Knight or
that Professor Xander from the kids next
door special there's probably others but
like those are the ones that immediately
come to mind one of the biggest
highlights of this special is the
Kick-Ass voice cast a bunch of guys from
Ninja Turtles here
and I love when Jim Cummings plays
villains so his evil duplicating Santa
sounds great now you guys are all
electric clothes of me right and the
more electricity the more clothes right
and where is the greatest power source
the city has the hydroelectric plant at
the city Dam this one's got a great
tongue-in-cheek sense of humor to it
that elevates a little bit above the
others on this list because it can also
get a chuckle out of me as an adult I
think of this show as being in the same
vein as like Animaniacs or Simpsons
where a kid in the 90s could enjoy it
with their parents after watching this
special alone I definitely want to check
out the rest of the show when I get the
time
[Music]
my favorite things about the 2003 TMNT
series is how it establishes that
Michelangelo is the best fighter on the
team he wins that big Multiverse
fighting tournament he hangs out with
superheroes he has an interestingly high
amount of solo episodes in the show away
from his three brothers
feels like this show was always
unintentionally foreshadowing a certain
comic Arc from Eastman Laird now that I
think about it but this Christmas
special sees Mikey and a stray cat he
adopted on an action-packed adventure to
stop a gang of criminals from stealing a
truckload of toys on Christmas Eve toys
that were inbound for needy and
underprivileged kids man [ __ ] those guys
you just know they're scalpers and they
were gonna put that [ __ ] up on eBay for
like three times the price it was the
day before these guys are the ones that
stopped me from getting my mom that
collectible Mark Ryden theme set of
Barbie dolls which is so oddly specific
that it was a perfect gift for her kill
them all Mike
ah he spares their lives but it's still
pretty good while he's off doing all
that die hard [ __ ] nearly the entire
cast of characters all hang out back of
the lair for a big Christmas party and
wait for him to show up I love this
episode because they actually bring back
tons of one-off characters from previous
seasons of the show and acknowledge that
the turtles are still maintaining
relationships with them even if it's off
screen for most episodes
this cast of characters is so eclectic
and weird you got a talking rabbit
samurai from Another Universe and
invulnerable superhero a group of normal
on house guys that the turtles sometimes
chill with that kid that they stopped
from joining a gang I love that this
cartoon remembers [ __ ] that happened in
previous episodes and builds on it
instead of just introducing dozens and
dozens of characters to only appear once
and then never see them again given that
we know what Splinter looks like in live
action I feel like seeing him in a Santa
outfit in real life would certainly
frighten me as a child but it's cartoon
logic and everyone at this orphanage
just kind of rolls with it it's like
when you're a mutated anthromorphic
reptile and you can comfortably go to
the movies as long as you dress like
Rorschach I love this episode two
clashing tones and story lines one is a
fast-paced never-ending Chase sequence
and the other is just like a wholesome
get-together with characters you know
and like and it's really satisfying when
the two plots come together at the end
[Music]
okay I've been kicking his ass all night
let's give ultimate Spidey some love
this Christmas special is like in my top
five episodes of this entire show
granted that's a low bar and believe me
finding five really decent ones out of
104 was harder than you'd expect this
episode has a depressed and Lonesome
Spidey on Christmas reliving some
memories of his early days as a
superhero which causes the art style to
change to something really cool and
classic I feel like this is what
Spider-Man freshman year will look like
in motion if it ever comes out
plus he starts recreating 60 Spider-Man
animations on his adventure and it's one
of the few times in this show that a
joke actually lands I dig it I just
sworn I swung down the street before
over and over
must be Deja Vu I wonder if Troy Baker
playing shocker and Montana in this
episode is like an intentional thing
because of the last one in addition to
the memories of Christmas Past Peter has
also shown a glimpse of the future if he
gives up being Spider-Man he's the CEO
of Parker Industries or whatever and all
the other superheroes have been killed
off by Norman Osborne going by the title
Goblin King he's given these Visions as
a form of reflection after being blamed
for Crime as per usual and being ditched
by the rest of his friends on Christmas
Eve but but spidey's indomitable human
Spirit can never be broken despite being
tested again and again and it turns out
this nightmarish glimpse into the future
was all a mystical scheme being
controlled by Nightmare
Mark Hamill guest stars as the dweller
of darkness and really helps round out
this episode as one of the best in the
whole series although again the bar is
kind of in hell
this episode is a really great
Spider-Man story on its own and feels
like it could have been a mid-2000s one
shot from the comics like the short
Halloween but better
sorry bad example
despite his pessimism Peter Parker will
never be able to throw away his hope for
a better tomorrow and that's why we love
him
of all these I think the static episode
is still by far my favorite I'm
wondering if I used up all the really
good ones of these in the first list a
few years back but I still have enough
material to fit like two more videos of
these
have a wonderful Christmas Kwanzaa
Hanukkah atheist gift exchange or die
hards validity is a Christmas movie
argument with your relatives day
you'll be on the nice list if you
subscribe and support me on patreon plus
you can check out our merch if you want
an incredibly belated gift for the
Godzilla Mendoza fan in your life who
you reasonably forgot to buy a gift for
because they're also as annoying and
forgettable as the host of this show
maybe I'd have better self-esteem if you
bought more of my junk on eBay because
I'm selling a treasure Trove nostalgic
toys on there that are still in the box
all right I'm done plugging [ __ ] I got
mouths to feed you understand see you
next time I hope your cat stops knocking
the tree over at night
[Music]
[Music]